Qu'est ce qu'on va pouvoir faire comme vidéo aujourd'hui putain j'ai pas d'idées !
Ahhhhhh !!!
Qu'est-ce que les gens veulent voir ?
Qu'est-ce qui ferait des vues !
Non.
Nooonn !!!
Je ne ferai pas une vidéo de merde sur ce jeu comme tout les YouTubeurs parce que ça fait des vues !
Je refuse de rentrer dans ce système !
Naann !!! Mais qui a lancé le jeu là ?!
OK ! Aujourd'hui on est sur le jeu le plus over hypé de tout les temps alias : Five Night At Freddy's
C'est le 26ème opus je crois ?
Bon allez allez allez cesse de
triquiter
On va faire une nouvelles partie on va voir ce que ça donne
Ça marche
Oh c'est nouveau !!!
Comment on s'appelle ?
Jean-Michel
Mais je peux rien marquer enculé tu vois bien que ça bouge !
Bon...
NON !!
C’était Jean-Michel mon blaze
Tu vas pas commencer à me saouler hein...
Et si tu comptes m'appeler à chaque début de niveau..
Je me désabonne de ta chaîne YouTube.
Nuit une !
Allez c'est parti.
D'accord, donc à gauche y'a une meuf qui danse,
Des fois elle danse pas faut que j'appuie là
Pour lui envoyer un petit électrochoc pour qu'elle se remette à danser,
Et là on passe donc à la vitre de droite,
Qu'est ce qui a de l'autre côté ?
Rien..
Et là c'est pareil je peux lui envoyer un petit électrochoc
Pour qu'il soit là.
Voilà.
Ooohh ! C'est cool ça !
Oui ok !
Et c'est ce conduit qui nous ramène d'une pièce...
Qui nous passe d'une pièce à l'autre.
D'accord ok.
Mais non, on va se faire choper dans le conduit comme des merdes !
Vous pouvez pas faire un couloir sinon normal
Où on peut courir dedans.
Y'a personne, 'faut mettre un électrochoc..
Mais attends,  il est où le bébé là ?!
Mais attends  je comprends pas. Vous voyez le bébé
De l'autre côté de la vitre ?!
Y'a rien !
Y'a RIEEEEEENN !
Allez faut retourner dans l'autre pièce,
Et euh la première nuit va pouvoir commencer.
Ah y'a quand même des petites...
C'est quoi ce bruit ?
Ooohhh je vais me barrer d'ici moi !!
OK !
Chuuuuut !!!
Oh y'a un blème,
Ok non, ou alors, juste on est arrivé je sais plus.
Je sais plus
Bon sachez juste que c'est l'ascenseur qui nous a amené au travail
Et en fait du coup on dirait une sorte de pizzeria mais un peu cabaret quoi.
Y'a des danseurs, des trucs,
C'est des robots.
Et nous on doit les faire
Euuuhhh
Danser et caetera
En gros on est le technicien quoi, on est là dans nos tuyaux,
Avec des câbles comme ça
Et faut que tout le monde danse
J'adore cette musique
Elle est trop bien
Je veux une version longue
Nique ta mère !
On sait très bien que l'histoire est vraie,
Et bientôt euuh
Un corps va être retrouvé mort,
Sur cette chaise
Allez est-ce qu'elle est en train de danser ?
Et bien non !!
C'est horrible on leur envoie des gros coup de jus pour qu'ils dansent..
Alors Foxy, il est là !
Il est prêt !
Allez on y va !
On va dans la pièce d'en face pour vérifier le bébé
Que d'ailleurs j'ai pas réussi à voir, tout à l'heure, à travers la vitre
Oh le bâtard !
Il me laisse totalement dans le noir quoi
Comme une vieille bite
Y'a un truc
J'ai entendu des bruits de la ventilation
Y'a un truc..
What the fuck ?!
Il me faut des thunes pour payer mon loyer c'est tout hein !
Ok
Super
Pas de eye contact
Ok
Super !
Ben merci c'est hyper rassurant
Putain l'intro du jeu est méga longue hein..
On est déjà à 70 minutes de vidéo
Under the desk
Grab Here
Ok je suis en train de fermer un truc
Et y'a des trous dedans
Et donc je pense qu'il faut que j’évite l'oeil
C'est ça ?
Ah putain il arrive..
Ben c'est bon y'a plus personne je peux y aller ?
Roh putain
Oh j'ai perdu l'habitude des jeux d'horreurs
Je chiale à chaque fois quoi
Tu t'es pris pour PV Nova ou quoi là ?
Pourquoi il s'ouvre ?
Pourquoi ça s'ouvre ?
Game Over
Alors là..
Faut m'expliquer
Bon mon gars là on va passer en mode vénère.
Là on va passer en mode vénère !
Allez ferme moi cette putain de porte de merde !
On va trouver l'endroit ou y'a pas de trous
Et dès qu'il va faire
Cling Cling Cling Cling
Avec un putain de piolet la
On va prendre la porte
On va la retenir comme ça
Ensuite on l’entrouvre
BRAH ! Coup de couteau on la remet !
BRAH !
Je me suis entraîné.
Oh merde !
J'ai plus le son !
Je peux pas savoir quand il ouvre la porte
Y'a le piolet
Essaye d'ouvrir mon gars tu y arriveras pas
Vas-y essaye d'ouvrir
Essaye d'ouvrir
Vas-y
Open the door
Hodor
Non !
Noon !!
Nooon !!!
Arrête !
Je peux pas faire mieux là !
STOP !!!
Arrête !
Mais putain comment je peux faire mieux ?!
STOP !
STOOOOOP !!!
Arrête !
MAIS MERDE !
MAIS NIQUE TA MÈRE !
Comment je peux mieux faire !?
La porte je la tiens !
Je suis comme ça le bébé il a plus de force que moi
Attends il dois y avoir une technique particulière
Pour tenir cette porte
Allez ose ouvrir
Ose ouvrir
Je t'attends mon gars
Non
Ahh !
Vous voyez ça marche mieux comme ça
En fait, 'faut juste cliquer et rester avec la main euhh
Fermée sur la poignée
Bon j'en sais rien mais ce mec il sait pas tenir une porte
Putain c'est pas compliqué
C'est bon il s'est barré !
Je peux y aller ?
Putain
Ok
Y'a trois conduits en fait
C'est pour ça que le tuto est si long
C'est qu'il y a mille fois plus d'éléments qu'avant.
Oh bordel c'est quoi ça ?
What the fuck mec ?
What the fuck !? Mais qu'est ce que je dois faire ?
D'accord
J'en ai marre c'est juste des screamers gratuits ce jeu
Putain la porte elle est loin
Ouais, ouais, ouais, ouais...
Allez barre-toi
Y'a la musique là
Si je bouge elle va me griller
Barre-toi
Elle est là !
Oh
C'est quoi ça ?
C'est la danseuse elle est passée devant
Elle est juste là !
Je l'entends tellement
STOP !
Allez on y va
C'est parti
Allez
Allez on y croit
Ben je fais quoi ?
Je fais quoi ?
Putain
Je suis vraiment nul
Je..
J'arrive pas a comprendre la logique là
Vous voyez là y'a pas de musique
Là la musique arrive
Là elle est là je m’arrête
Je peux y aller
BON !
Allez !
Bon ben écoutez les gens comme prévu
J'apprécie pas trop ce jeu
Par contre j'avoue il a complétement changé le gameplay et ça je trouve ça vraiment cool
Maintenant il suffit plus juste de checker les caméras comme ça et de fermer une porte
Quand le monstre est là
C'est beaucoup plus complexe y'a beaucoup plus d'éléments
Et des nouvelles mécaniques je trouve ça cool
Après j'avoue
Ça me
Ça me fait pas kiffer à mort.
Ben écoutez si vous avez 6,79€ à dépenser
Allez-y
Et puis dites moi si vous avez kiffé.
Les gens ont apparemment carrément kiffé sur steam
Et ça m’étonne pas puisque c'est bien foutu
Mais voilà c'est pas mon délire
Merci d'avoir regardé
N’hésitez pas a aimer la vidéo si ça vous a quand même plu
Par contre les screamers on les supporte plus du tout
Là on arrive à un stade où on ne peut plus
C'est la vieillesse on vieillit
On se fait vieux
Et notre petit cœur est sensible
Allez à toutes pour une prochaine vidéo
Merci d'avoir regardé
Portez-vous bien
Ciao tout le monde,
PEACE !